what I'm talking about like making out
with a man
Hearts already did that I'm not making
up that's too easy come on yeah that's
too easy no that's the hardest part yeah
that's very intimate yeah
imagine kids
[Music]
welcome everybody to another amazing
episode of the careful boys and today we
have silent Mike back in the seat oh
yeah
are we doing off the records we are
doing it off the Record where we are
currently uh on the record off the
Record excellent you Rebel so we just
asked one of our lovely patients in our
live stream to give us an off the Record
prompt and this is
The Prompt if you had 24 hours left to
live what would you do
I'm so boring I have no ambitions for
reals kinda what would you do would you
be like I'll do it probably like a
buffet deal something you know I like
eat till you stuff yeah I probably go
like pizza buffet Chinese buffet that's
your first thought
what are you trying to jump on an
airplane or something that's not even
like family yeah yeah mom's coming to
the buffet with me okay would you or
like whip a car around that'd be cool go
like 800 miles per hour or something go
fight still Ferrari would you spend any
of that time taking a nap
I hate naps I don't know how do you hate
a nap I never heard of such a thing I
love it against them I wake up grumpy I
wake up grumpy and I wake up tired that
means you're sleep deprived no I sleep
what you're gonna die anyways you should
die grumpy yeah I sleep hella good I
sleep like 10 hours a night wow oh that
that means you're over sleeping are you
gonna like are you gonna like try drugs
you've never tried before oh maybe
everyone says shrooms are cool shoes are
cool but that might last you a few hours
so well I'll be driving a Rari with
shrooms on who cares I'm about to die so
you really if you had 24 hours to Live
you wouldn't change a single thing I I'm
just not that ambitious with crazy [__]
because everyone's like oh I want to go
like ride an elephant or something like
wow there's not even that way I wrote an
elephant there's not that one chick out
there that you're gonna be like I'm
gonna hit her up today all fun like yeah
Megan Fox's house or something that'd be
cool on the Rari on shrooms oh [__] pull
up yeah you know can you do that for the
Make-A-Wish round I think they should
have a wait makeup for an adult station
yeah for adults like who would you like
to [__] you're like you know what I've
been I've been wanting to [__] Megan
Kelly
she's the Republican reporter
you Transformers I was like it's either
Megan Fox or Machine Gun Kelly no it's
Megan Kelly
you guys better come with some hot ass
answers if you're judging mine
you got a hot ass yeah
you guys fake dude I'm gonna tell you
I'll tell you what was going on in my
brain yeah you want to hear what's going
on in my brain so the first thing that I
started thinking about is am I gonna be
a planner or a what the [__] did you
just say a planner you have to be on
your last day so for example am I okay I
got 24 hours right am I a [__] a
Winger a Winger or a planner Winger
these I don't think those are words dude
you gotta listen all right the doctor
goes we only got 24 hours to live Mike
yeah a Winger just starts winging it
right yeah no I understand the concept
You Toby don't know these words I don't
think Winger is a [__] concept a word
a planner is like okay chill give me two
hours to plan my next 22 hours you
wasted two hours
there's left there's left Wingers in
right wing a soccer and hockey oh and
politics so I was thinking am I would I
wing it or would I plan it that's what I
was thinking about first I didn't go
blank you're building a plan to build a
plan do you
because I'll tell you what I was trying
to do okay I was like okay I think I
might have to plan because I want to try
to cram 30 hours within 24 hours so what
can I do to really maximize and then at
the 23rd and 55 minute Mark I'm gonna
have cocaine I'm gonna have the guy with
the clits all that [__] because I'm
gonna be like [__] you doctor I'm gonna
see if I can stay awake somehow at the
last 24th hour so right when the
doctor's like okay and three well who
says two doctors give me all this [__]
[__] heroin everything and then I'll
see you like oh if I can [__] beat
this 24. he dies in one hour instead of
24 I hope you lived but then and see if
I could beat that motherfucker's
neckline I showed you I Live 24 hours
five hours what did you do in those
planned ass 30 hours though what's that
what'd you do in your plan 30 hours what
are you talking about you had 30 hours
planned into 22 hours no The Rock The
Rock type [__] like
yeah I get a haircut while I'm in the
train that's two things and you have to
put it on Instagram otherwise the world
doesn't know how cool you are yeah
that's why I use the two hours to make
my 22 hours last 30 hours that's what I
was thinking about so you double up on
experiences or maybe I just wing it I
don't know so what's a good pairing of
experiences so you get a haircut on a
train would you get a massage on a boat
that sounds fun
all right I'd like to be you guys are
brilliant
would you like
what you got
a haircut
thousand haircuts and I've lived 30
years you guys judge stuff I get a
facial at the mall
I'll turn on the late Late Show maybe
watch David Letterman
see you know most most people most
people be like oh I want to do the
things that I never experienced before
but I'm not a low life like you guys so
look at this what I would do is I would
be used for people like something
dangerous where it's like oh someone's
gonna die but they gotta do it and I'll
be like
I'll [__] volunteer because like I
remember
um you know the nuclear spill yeah the
nuclear spill in [__] Fukushima some
people had to clean up that [__] and
then they're like if you do it though
your family will be taken care of we'll
give you this about so then they just
literally sacrificed themselves to do it
and some people that had terminal
illnesses they're just like well [__] it
I'm gonna die off cancer anyway so they
went and cleaned up all the nuclears
very Japanese yes but before but what I
would do is
um right before I got a radioactive body
I'd ask for a triple [__]
one on the Dick one on the ball and one
on the ass oh three ways oh it's a three
for one what's your position yeah where
are you are you
a Jeep Wrangler you got your ankles tied
up you're upside down I'm doing come to
me but with my legs yeah and glowing
yeah that would be every every night so
on the daytime every night you got 24
hours one night yeah shift workers
coming in every shift every four hour
shift every night so so I get I'm not
right I nut and then I go out and I do
some humanitarian [__] you know I'm
cleaning up the [__]
toxic waste with the mop and [__] that's
all you have to do and then I go into
the the blow job Room everybody who's
blowing you is getting terminally ill
now yeah I guess I thought it's not like
AIDS bro you can't contract it from that
I thought we were all dying not just me
no just you you're allowed yeah you know
what I mean I thought the apocalypse was
coming that's why I'm doing shrooms in
the Rari but that's dangerous yeah
you took it as the whole world I thought
the world's exploded so self-centered no
shape of the entire world I thought we
were all dead I thought we were all dead
otherwise I'm on Jody I'm sweeping up
toxins or some dog [__] I guess
I'm adopting every dog in the world and
finding them homes or some [__]
I'm about to take care of them and you
know in 24 hours every every gunfight
that's going down I'm just eating them
just saving lives you gotta be like you
want to be that guy that's like already
bit by the zombie so you're like I'll
take it for the team you guys go run
running towards the zombies instead of a
way you be that guy what would you guys
do
I'll probably clean up nuclear waste I
think yeah see we're good guys we're
good guys yeah definitely Bart's only
getting a [__] haircut on a train I'm
I'm probably gonna do some wild drug
like Ayahuasca yeah but why because
you're gonna be already high when you
die yeah but because like
there's that
maybe there's this concept or this idea
that if you your life enters a different
frequency of understanding maybe the way
that you transition into death won't be
so like that's true yeah it's not like
the dichotomy just life and death you
know what I mean yeah there's almost
like something Beyond life that you've
experienced and maybe there's something
Beyond debt that you welcome yourself
into when you get into it that's what
scares me because I feel like if I'm on
Ayahuasca right then my body teleports
and when I come back there's nobody to
receive me back and then I'm lost into
as a ghost oh that's also a different
kind of deep because I'm like where's my
body at oh man and then like when you're
high you're just so hot so you're like
out of your body you come back where's
my body it's [__] hanging upside down
getting eaten out in their [__]
Direction yeah
that's that'll be cool and two on the
nipples
see he's compressing time too yeah would
you guys make fun of me and [__] that's
official that's what's compressing all
the time compressing time is an
accusations funny
what would you do I think I would I
would want to try drugs I think too oh
yeah you're sober never done anything
anything what's the first one you would
try what do you suggests is good for you
think he'll do it like once every hour
like no I would just do one thing that I
think because I mean my tolerance is
probably super fun if you do a little
bit of Adderall it'll probably like
it'll make your day it'll make your day
go like it starts writing an essay
you'd be really cool if you had to
choose one smoke some crack
probably I didn't craft the best one
that's why it's so addictive what about
heroin you think heroines no I think
heroin's it yeah heroin's like point of
no return Ray Charles or yeah all those
guys be taking those crazy now that you
said Adderall for some reason that makes
me think of all the [__] logistical
[__] and this is a boring practical
answer but if I had 24 hours for real to
live all the things I never took care of
that I have to take care of before my
family suffers you're gonna write a will
yeah I bet you the last 24 hours I'm
gonna just [__] end up doing [__] to
make it easier for my family all the
responsible [__] all the task things you
know what I mean like we want to spend
time went through hell of [__] because
[__] wasn't like cleaned up and taken
care of or like you know the next person
yeah yeah Dad
that stuff is crazy annoying but yeah I
don't have a will you know I haven't
[__] put one of those things in yeah
and you probably want to spend time with
your wife oh no yeah I would want to do
that and then and then at the last at
the very last like few minutes I'd want
to like Freestyle a last song and die in
the middle of it oh so and record it and
then have it be like oh that's what I
want a tight rope that's tired
with the audience of your your closest
friends and family or no like that's a
sick ass recording because there's no
recording of anybody ever playing piano
and then if it ended on the wrong note
oh then I'll come back to life
how poetic would that be if his head
drops on the right key oh [__] that
should be tight yeah I think it'd be
really cool or he's like singing to it
and then the last words then I'm out
what the hell TLC song am I singing he's
rapping I'm out mic drop body drop
crisscross the acoustic version he
turned clothes backwards first yeah
that'd be cool that's a good practical
one so I'll get haircut on the train and
then and then I'll plan it while I'm
getting the hair if you're married isn't
it simple
yeah I think they just was the wifey I
think the law is pretty simple when
you're married there's that stuff she
don't know my crypto keys but yeah
exactly there's just [__] oh yeah
there's just so much [__] yeah my Gmail
account do you all have life insurance
everybody I think I do I do I think I
got scammable you can collect on it when
your terminal you don't have to die yeah
I think you can clicked on it depending
on the way yeah I could buy collect on
it now and buy that Rory sorry what'd
you say I said Ryan's wild why do you
guys have life insurance just in case I
die because I'm not Immortal I don't
know why my mom got it for me when my
dad died [__] maybe I should get life
insurance well you don't have it the
fact that Joe doesn't have life
insurance like that's a dangerous
concept well maybe because I live the
way I do the [__] insurance companies
won't take me it does get weird as you
get older I got it like 23 in there
hella hard why did you get it so young I
think his dad died mom's like oh maybe
we just do this it's a good idea yeah
you get it so cheap when you're 23 bro
yeah I paid like I paid like 50 bucks a
year so what did your dad have life
insurance when he died we thought he did
but I don't think he did and my dad
worked in insurance I don't even
remember my dad my whole life from my
20s got foggy I don't remember damn
trauma will do that to you yeah it [__]
your [__] up I don't remember those
[__] Rari drugs oh yeah shrooms
[__] up my whole 20s
heroin I think said though when we're
talking drugs what's an honest if I
given to you in your last 24 hours yeah
probably drugs yeah probably because I
don't really do drugs if I had to go out
it'll probably be somewhere heroin they
say like every song in the 70s is about
heroin it's got to be [__] fun that's
probably your last like three hours I
think the reason why I want to stay
sober is because this is the time that I
have to actually stay in reality because
I feel like when I die I'm in a
different Zone anyway and I'm probably
gonna feel like I'm high you want to
hear something gay yep probably the last
24 hours I probably want to like hold my
wife's hand and hold my kid obviously
you for sure would no I I like that
can I hold me or something I ain't got
no one to hold you want to hear
something gay I want to hold my wife's
hand yeah yeah no I get that though yeah
obviously you would do that they would
be on the train with you with a fresh
face yeah Tiger's giving you a haircut
yeah yeah you're getting the fresh face
[__] your [__] up dude
it's like it's having a blast yeah
that's gonna have to be a closed casket
that haircut is [__] up
we can't be showing that [__]
and then I'll have a toolbox full of
feathers and glue and whatever and he
could do whatever the [__] he wants in
my head you know what that's actually a
fun one yeah what would you do with
taika if you're last like [__] yeah
if you would let him do whatever the
[__] he would want to do that day like
what kind of [__] to be honest if it was
to make his dream come true yeah I'd
probably be butt naked going side to
side while he's throwing ninja stars
so
you don't think in the future he would
feel weird that that was his dream come
also traumatize him but it's like this
is my last day but I want this for you
he would love it honestly he would
[__] love that's pretty funny
actually the paper ones the real ones
you're about to die might as well yeah
probably real or you hire a bunch of
actors to recreate home alone and he's
[__] Macaulay Culkin oh maybe yeah he
might like that oh yeah he gets to set
traps that's pretty cool or a three
ninja situation dude oh yeah you gotta
drink the [__] diarrhea soda
oh the diarrhea soda let's go uh me and
my mom try to do this thing for my
grandma when she was dying so we had
pictures of her um old room like when
she was uh still like normal before like
Dimension all that [__] and then we were
like she still had her same like vanity
mirror and things like that so we try to
recreate it as close as possible so she
feels like she's in her own house that's
cool yeah but doesn't that confuse the
[__] out of it it was difficult because
she didn't have you know how old people
think they keep things forever but they
don't have the same exact things so I
think that threw her off because it was
just like wait it looks like my room but
this thing is offer and when we went
back all of the pictures that she had
hanging she put it away oh so it was
weird also are we not all like doing
like you know testing gayness in our
last 24 hours or anything like that's
the first thing that came into your mind
um I don't think I am the last part of
the video the first thing yeah I was
asking for Bart what about like making
out the man
Hearts already did that I'm not making
out that's too easy come on yeah that's
too easy no that's the hardest part yeah
that's very intimate yeah
imagine kids
that's that's the hard part
your lips
is it Morgan Freeman yeah the button
redemption not the bucket list oh Shank
Redemption kisses his way out of jail I
think I'll watch that shot on an
airplane they're doing like all these
like skydiving all the bucket list yeah
yeah yeah are they terminally ill in
that I think he is but they ain't got 24
hours they got like a minute I think
they got like six months these are very
conflicting times maybe travel somewhere
cool you got a minute six months travel
somewhere would be cool but 24 hours
you're already losing half your time of
[__] there I know I need like a NASA
to like sponsor me and get me there or
something go to the Moon let NASA Just
Launch me uh go to outer space and die
up there to die once you vaporize in a
second I mean I'll have a student I'm in
a ship yeah they're not launching in
like a human body I'm not a squirrel
suit
just the Rockies don't worry I just
disintegrate in the [__] he's still
in the Rari on shrew a Halloween costume
space suit yeah just launch it up in the
[__]
you know that would be sick I mean now
we're talking about Dreamland but you
know right before dying if we could just
get launched into space so we can just
see Earth yeah that'd be kind of tired
that's not that long I know what I want
to do I feel really for the last minute
of my death is I'm gonna be [__]
Hannah and when I bust a nut I want to
die at that moment so my soul transfers
into her ovaries while it gets uh
spermicided and no post not Clarity oh
yeah no you just go tell you everything
yeah and then when I come I come inside
yeah and it's guaranteed it's not gonna
traumatize her that somebody just died
in it and then I reincarnate as her
child oh that's weird
let me be a [__] though no I
think you would
technically that would be your title
yeah it's your signature move you know
I'll enter as my son and me
Logistics wise I'll be my son and me at
the same time physically I am my son but
my soul transferred in and I
reincarnated do you think that would
mess with Hannah
having a son that's also her husband
that's [__] crazy
you know it will be a suspend situation
oh that sounds like straight to a VHS
movie
[Music]
foreign